I'm not going to argue a Chris if Chris  tells me to see this on an IMAX screen  I'm going to watch on an IMAX Creek  I'm going don't Kirk the film is an  incredible spectacle and it's just  fantastic in the big screen and the  music and it's a real experience movies  don't get made like this very often and  it's a very special kind of movie to see  on an epic screen which is just going to  swallow your soul  it is completely different when you see  an iMac it powers intended to watch you  want to come out and and really sit back  and let this roll over you like a big  tidal wave I mean it's such a  white-knuckle ride when you watch it and  I map it's so completely engaging from  the second the first bullet fly through  the air to the very last one Christopher  Nolan Virginia  you  you